Speaker 1: But here's one person who
doesn't necessarily care if Donald Trump
is innocent or guilty or what the heck happens
to him and that person happens to be his spouse.
Former First Lady Melania Trump. After several
weeks of trying to just ignore all of the legal
problems that her husband is facing. Melania
Trump finally came out this week and released
a statement attacking the media for all of their
reporting on her allegedly not giving one single
care about what is happening to her husband.
So let me read you this statement, because
I don't think the statement really
says what Melania had wanted it to say.
Here it is. News organizations have made
assumptions about the former first lady's
stance on subjects that are personal, professional
and political. Over the past few weeks in these
articles, unnamed sources are cited to bolster
the author's claims. We ask readers to exercise
caution and good judgment when determining whether
or not stories concerning the former First lady
are accurate, particularly when they fail to
cite Mrs. Trump as a source of information.
So you're not actually saying that they're
not accurate. You're just saying, hey, folks,
you may want to think for a minute
and then decide if it's accurate.
But you you're you're not denying the stories by
telling people make up your own mind. Like, that's
that's what they were already doing. You don't
have to tell people to make up their own minds
because they've already made up their own minds.
And these reports citing anonymous sources. Sure,
I know how much that drives your crazy down there
in Republican land. But they're talking to sources
close to you. They're talking to people who know
you, people who work for you, people who have been
around you for years. And they don't want to be
named because they probably don't want to lose
their jobs. Kind of seems like a pretty easy
gig, if you ask me. Probably pays pretty well.
And yeah, you don't want to lose it, but you also
want the public to know what's really happening.
So what we know from Melania Trump, based on
recent reporting, I mean, we've had reports,
you know, Rolling Stone, Vanity Fair, you know,
pretty much all major outlets, The Daily Beast.
Melania Trump, as we all know, did not attend her
husband's victory speech after his indictment and
arraignment last Tuesday. So she didn't show
up for that. Previous reports before that even
happened, said Melania Trump wants nothing
to do with her husband's legal problems.
She's going about living her life. She lives in
a separate wing at Mar a Lago. They do not share
living quarters, so they're not even sleeping
in the same bed. So that's usually a pretty big
indication that there are some marital problems
there. And these reports say that Melania spends
most of her days happy with with Barron and
her parents, who also live down there. And
they're just going about their lives as if none
of this is even happening. Good for her. Right.
I'm not going to fault you for that. Your marriage
appears based on what we see to be falling apart,
you know, based on all of the, you know, visual
evidence. You don't even seem to like the guy.
I, honest to God, can't figure out why you're even
still with him. You. You look miserable all the
time when you're around him. And then when there's
photos or videos of you with not Donald Trump,
you seem to look happy. I mean, you know, it
doesn't take a marriage counselor to understand
that you are happier when you're not with this
guy. So maybe it's time to cut bait and just say,
hey, thanks, but I'm out. Either way, it's
your life. You do whatever you want, but
you're your little message here,
your denial of the stories,
which isn't actually a denial that doesn't
help your case. It just makes it sound like,
hey, some of these may be true, some of them
may not be. Who knows? I don't know. Do you?
Not exactly the stellar statement that you thought
you were making. So, I don't know, maybe go back
to the drawing board, maybe come up with a better
statement, maybe deny the stories or help, maybe
confirm them, put it all to rest. The focus is on
your husband anyway. Nobody wants to be talking
about Melania. She's not doing anything. Like I
said, she's living her life and seemingly happy.
But don't go out there and poke the
media and accuse them of things when
you're not even denying the things that they're
reporting. That's not exactly honest either.